[Applause]
what do you guys think about uh caitlyn
jenner
uh what she said about the trans
athletes
it's just so funny her whole approach
with all that [ __ ] why like because like
republican against same-sex marriage
against
trans athletes in sports has she said
specifically she's against same-sex
marriage i believe so yeah yeah i think
she said that early on yeah it was a
while ago i got to see where she said
that probably reverse her stance because
she got it when she started pushback
no i think i think she followed up with
i'm a traditional woman or something
like that
i thought that she was against
homosexuality uh
because she doesn't see herself as
homosexual yeah exactly i'm a
traditional woman
and like but then didn't you say she's
not attracted to men
i don't know what this [ __ ] is but i
know that i agree with her when it comes
to
the trans athletes i do they basically
ask her like do you think that
trans athletes so for example a a man
that becomes a woman
should be able to now compete with women
in like high school i think they were
saying yeah
but i think let's just take this to all
sports um
and and yeah of course not why is why
this is an issue is absolutely besides
me
men and women cannot compete in sports
because men are better than women in
most sports
in the things we're not better at them
at we compete together
there's no like women's chess and men's
chess there's just chess
women happen to not be very good at it
except on netflix is the only place
they're very good at but but they can
compete together because
there's no uh there's no difference in
the cognitive ability that men and women
have at least when it comes to playing
chess
right but when it comes to lifting heavy
things
men can do that more yes we are better
at lifting heavy things i'm not hiring
an all-female moving company
you can judge me if you want to but i'm
not doing it
why not dude i just don't want to pay
that hourly rate for so many more hours
oh dude i would watch that every single
day just all
lift more to do so yeah god came looking
like me i kicked that [ __ ] out
of my house
all female moving companies just
watching like 30 of them move a couch
like ants
moving a banana peel right that would be
amazing unless you get them on the one
week where they're all synced up
oh then they got that super strength
yeah then they're able to go super
saiyan and just
eat chocolate between moving [ __ ] yeah
anyway it's like it seems like such a
no-brainer i don't understand why could
it be
what if we based it on when you started
the the gender change what about if we
don't and we just say you're a guy and i
understand that you want to masquerade
as a girl and that's fine and if we have
to call you a girl because it makes you
feel more comfortable
cool if you want to wear girls clothes
that's amazing but you don't get to
beat up girls that were born as girls
because you could [ __ ] hurt them
because you have a huge advantage
it's like no brainer hypothetical what
if you go the other way
that never happens tony hinchcliffe has
a great joke about this so i don't want
to like
i don't want to touch on his joke but he
basically does say that uh
there aren't a lot of athletes that go
the opposite way yeah there's not a lot
of trans
men that choose to play men's sports
yeah
because they can right simple as that
you there is a difference like why are
we acting like there's not a difference
but that happened though there is like
that story mauricia
there was that story so basically a girl
transitions to a guy gets on
testosterone and like
all the hormones to transition into a
guy yeah
and then wants to compete in wrestling
yeah and then like the
state athletic commission was like no
you have to compete against women yeah
and so now dominated now this guy is
like i don't want to beat against women
because i'm going to dominate them
yeah and then he goes in and dominates
everyone now did he get to wrestle the
guys
no because the athletic commission said
you have to compete with the gender that
you're born with
and so he goes well [ __ ] and now he has
all this testosterone exactly so it's a
huge advantage and is like lifting crazy
like bone densities going up muscle's
going up
yeah you you don't get to compete is
that the girl in the tick tock that she
goes like that
somebody out the frame no that girl is
ripped that girl's amazing i love those
tick tocks
uh but no in those situations you don't
get to compete yeah sorry dude what if
you started the uh
whatever the process that whatever you
call it at like age three
so now your parents should be shot in
the head your parents should be shot in
their [ __ ] head if you're a
transitional
kid at three years after we shoot the
power he's really sucking on that
pacifier i think it's a girl
six seven eight whatever before puberty
before [ __ ] really
starts to go hormonally one way what if
you start then
seven eight years old the kid is like i
know what i am this is what i want to do
your parents should go to prison
okay how are you not seeing this okay so
now after you send the parents to prison
would you allow that kid to compete in
support
no not at all
um because you're not allowed to
okay that's fine i understand what
you're saying now what he's saying is if
he transitioned early enough where you
wouldn't have the positive side effects
of having extra
hormones in your body testosterone
disparities exactly yeah so so
essentially you would uh present like
whatever gender you chose in that moment
right that's what you're saying yeah yes
i guess that should be good but
nobody should be allowed to transition
at eight years old i mean you don't even
let your kid choose what food goes in
their mouth at eight years old
you literally go no candy until after
you eat your vegetables right you're not
gonna go no
[ __ ] growing out of your body until
after you eat your vegetables
right like so it i mean are you
supportive of that like kids getting
testosterone therapy at eight
i don't know what the age is but i don't
yeah i don't think you support it at 18.
like if we're being entirely honest here
i understand the argument
nothing yeah no no hey listen once you
turn
18 do whatever the [ __ ] you want with
your body if we can send you to war then
you could send you i mean you're losing
things in war
people come back for more missing [ __ ]
that's what that's what trans people
should really do like i listen i was
you know i was dry humping some dirt and
kabul and there's a mine went off and uh
you know that's my whole
what do you [ __ ] out there right it's
not like they got brothels
when trump banned people from the
military i was like that's [ __ ] up you
should just do
encourage trans people to go in the
military why just soup them up like give
them all the testosterone get them
[ __ ] jacked
yeah in america yeah like go full like
cyborg do we allow roids in the military
that's interesting i don't know why we
don't
i think we should everyone should just
be on peds it's the next disney
is the next disney movie just captain
america but trans yes like
they they walk in they take the super
serum goes from a girl to a [ __ ]
brolic ass that's a good point yeah
killing it if you're already
transitioning you're like yeah [ __ ]
transition me with you know
cyborg parts give me like a [ __ ] gun
on my arm i mean can we look it sucks
obviously if you feel like you're born
the wrong body
i have tons of empathy for that because
that must [ __ ] suck but you're a
douchebag to compete against the new
gender
like you're a [ __ ] [ __ ] dude are
you not hit it al
okay go how many women sports do you
watch right now
oh that's a good point you don't watch
dude i've been watching the cooking
channel nonstop
that's what i'm saying it's like we
don't watch them now
let them compete it might get good um
oh you're saying like have actually mark
has a joke about this how dwayne wade's
daughter is going to [ __ ] save the
wnba yeah yeah yeah
it might get good it's going to light up
yeah but it's not going to get good
because there are women doing it
it doesn't matter i guess i hear what
you're saying
you want to be educated but i'm still
not going to watch like
a little bit worse dudes do the sports
g-league yeah like do you watch tv
what if they start like that
i guess i heard what you're saying but
like we can't have that conversation
like we can't sit down with the trans
athletes just be like hey bro
or whatever just like yo you you really
want to do this to girls bro
like you really want to do this with
their head they're a girl
but are they
[Laughter]
when they got to go pee do they squat
behind a [ __ ] toyota tundra
yeah and hope that their friend blocks
them every time i see a girl pee it's
behind a toyota tundra and their friend
is blocking them is that what they do or
they just pull that [ __ ] dangling out
and piss like a dude on a brick wall
in a [ __ ] alley what about post-op
can they compete huh if they got the
dick chopped off
it's not about the dick or not it's
really just about the competitive
advantage that a man has over a woman
because of testosterone yeah but you
gave a little leeway for if they started
the
hormone therapy earlier son can i just
give you let me say let me let me ask
you this question
would you be fine you know them slap
competitions where the people just stand
in front of each other and slap the [ __ ]
at each other
would you be fine if a trans woman so a
man that transitioned into a woman
was in that with a bunch of women bro
ufc that [ __ ] would be hilarious
ufc i might prefer that that was
hilarious puerto ricans
i would just like to have like an honest
sit down i understand that you care
about sports i understand that you want
to compete and i understand you're not
at a slight disadvantage with the dues
because you've been taking this estrogen
that sucks but don't you feel like you
kind of cheating being with these girls
bro
you don't feel like that come on dude
not at all i mean they're not going to
care who's not going to care
the trans person that you're asking this
question to they're not going to care
they want to play the sport that they
love and they feel like they're a woman
in the head
so now my question is why can't they
play in the men's league i just say you
[ __ ] they can't it's just not good
enough but like 100 percent
i mean a hundred jenner did and she was
really good at it she's the greatest
trans athlete of all time when you think
about it yeah
so it's like she was a trans athlete she
excelled she won all the medals all that
[ __ ]
you can play with the men nobody's
saying you can't play with the men bruce
could have done that [ __ ] with nails on
with [ __ ] heels do whatever you want
there's a play there's a player where
you can win with wokeness and say you
know what
we're just taking gender out of this uh
forever all leagues are
whoever's the best is the best and then
you got the wnba they don't i mean the
nba again there's no wnba anymore it's
just all dudes smoke bruh but that's
what that but you can out woke it you
can get
in front of the vocals and you're like
you know what guys you're right gender
is a social conscious gender is a social
construct we are eliminating the wnba
the nba will be open to all genders
whoever's the best can play yeah
now it'll be you'll get the [ __ ]
giant pat on the back
and then you got the nba and the wnb's
then you're gonna see the reverse level
what can we have a women's league
we wouldn't do that to you gender social
construct why would we do such a sexist
backwards thing
yeah so that's you just got to get in
front of them because they can't they
woke themselves into a circle
these people so you just got to get in
front of it and just trap them you know
what the real issue is that like we
build sports into this thing of value
that's really what it comes down to like
sports don't have to be the thing of
value
we could create sport a sport out of
anything like if
giving birth with a sport was a sport
and like pushing the baby out as fast as
you possibly could
if that was a sport women dominate yeah
yeah they absolutely dominate and like
if for whatever reason we just chose
that that was the coolest thing to watch
and then we were watching on tuesdays
and fridays on tnt and charles barkley
and [ __ ] ernie johnson will be
talking that [ __ ] every single day
and bargaining like damn you got some
strong [ __ ] lips squeezing that baby
out real quick
that if that was what society cared
about they would have this huge
advantage they'd be making millions of
dollars
and we would be out here like [ __ ] we
gotta find ways to like
i don't know squeeze eggs out of our
[ __ ] or something like that like we'd
have like the male
version of nobody will watch it nobody's
like welcome you're not watching why
don't we get paid the same as the women
and we'd be subsidizing they'd be like
because you're just squeezing eggs out
of your [ __ ] it's not even a real
sport you're not even really giving
birth
we've made up what sports are yeah it's
bitcoin it's crypto
we've just decided that this thing
called sports has value and it sucks
because women are at a disadvantage
you